hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel unfortunately I'm kind of
starting to get my life together here
which is great because it means that
I'll be able to post videos a little bit
more often they'll be coming more
regularly in about two weeks though once
I have a little bit more time and I'm
back in the US
um just quick announcement congrats to
pranav who hit me up on LinkedIn uh was
laid off was able to get another job
um accredits this channel for some
amount of help though I doubt it because
all I do is act like an idiot and
blabber about systems design so congrats
to you pronov congrats on staying in
America and uh yeah let's get into
today's video which is about
serialization Frameworks all right so
let's quickly go ahead and do this video
so I can go and get some food so
basically the premise of the problem is
this I have this field called a person
object as you can see it has myself my
attractiveness level and my girlfriend
and her attractiveness level and I want
to be able to hold this data on a
database and additionally you know it's
probably going to be sent from some
server to the database so it'd be nice
if you know we found a good way to go
ahead and encode this data somehow and
send it from our server to a database so
basically the traditional way of
actually holding this piece of data on a
database would be with a SQL or a
relational database so let's imagine we
had some table called person and I'll go
ahead and write that down and then in
person we would have IDs for every
single row we would have the names the
attractiveness and then foreign ID or in
this case it wouldn't be foreign because
it's the same table but another ID that
actually points to the person so in this
case the ID of my girlfriend would be
two and that would be pointing to Karina
Kopp who I'm obviously dating
so another way of doing this is to
actually store the data in a more
denormalized fashion right because the
issue with the relational model is that
if I want to have all of the data in my
record accessible in one place this is
not necessarily possible so in the
relational model you know you might have
multiple tables that are combined in
order to fetch one single record you
know if uh for example I had like um
a YouTube videos table and I had ideas
showing that I was the one creating them
I would have to go to the YouTube videos
table in order to fetch all of the
YouTube videos that I've created so for
example now what we have is some other
basically ways of storing this data in
more of a key value format and the ways
that databases might actually do them so
the common ones are going to be things
like Json and XML right so these are
just plain text formats in ways in which
we can effectively store data and look
at them and read them and it makes
things pretty simple right so the what I
have on the left here is basically Json
where I have some Field named person and
then I go ahead using brackets to list
out all of the other data that's there
and that's great because they're human
readable but at the same time these have
a lot of issues as well so even though a
lot of us use Json for example in just
like making our own web app in a massive
company these are not too feasible the
reasoning being they're less typesafe so
Json for example is hard to distinguish
between types of numbers and there's
some issue use there with XML as well
but more importantly there's a ton of
overhead with Json and XML so if you
look here I'm writing out the field
person a bunch of times and writing out
the word name attractiveness girlfriend
and the truth is if I know that every
single Row in my database has all of
these fields consistently I don't
actually have to write those out I can
store this data in a much more efficient
format thus saving me a ton of space so
why is it good to save us a ton of space
well for starters it means that there's
less disk usage that we're going to be
having in our company and also it means
if we're sending data from a server over
to the database there's less that
actually has to travel over the network
so basically you know we want this data
locality and by doing so we would prefer
to use something like a serialization
library so I'm going to go ahead and
show you how those works so the example
of serialization libraries that I'm
first going to talk about are things
like Google's protocol buffers and
Apache Thrift and the way these work are
as follows so we've got basically some
sort of message so a message would just
kind of be think of it as like the row
of your database and in this case it
would be named person
so what we're going to do here is give
every single field in our person message
a number and this is how these things
work so we would say there's some name
field that's going to be required and
the kind of index of it is number one or
not even an index but just basically the
field tag is what it's called then we
have our attractiveness field with an
INT type again this is typesafe which is
great and that's going to be field
number two and then finally an optional
girlfriend field because well Karina
Koff doesn't have a girlfriend but I do
so as you can see what we can now do is
when we store these things on disk it
allows us to not have to list out the
word person name attractiveness
girlfriend every single time we can
literally just keep a mapping from the
tag number to the field value so in this
case you know tag number one means that
I am sending uh the word name is equal
to Jordan so that's very important it
saves us a ton of space especially
because one can be represented in binary
as just either a literal one or you know
say we have four fields in total or
three Fields here I can just use
effectively o1 so again by effectively
just using uh these kind of small
mappings from field tags to field names
we can save a ton of space on disk in
addition to that these actual files of
messages are useful for other
programmers they just act as good
documentation they show the fields off
that are in your data so it's easier to
reason about what exactly is in your
database or what exactly is being sent
over the network
this does come at the cost of course of
being not human readable right so as you
can see down here uh basically we have
to serialize or encode our data using
the actual message format itself and
what that means is that in the actual
database the data is not stored as like
physical text but it's stored as a bunch
of zeros and ones and so you know we
would have to go ahead and deserialize
it so there is some CPU penalty that
comes with that but again it is
oftentimes worth it for the amount of
storage that it gets saved
okay so one thing that we've covered now
is that we do have to have basically
some files that list out what the format
of our data is however that itself kind
of leads to some problems because why
data basically just evolves over time
we're eventually going to want to add
some fields to this and it wouldn't be
acceptable if we weren't able to do that
right so keep in mind we have this
person message before and we had that
name attractiveness and girlfriend field
and now I want to go ahead and add some
other field called net worth right well
what I actually have to do is just go
ahead and add it as an optional field
because we know that any existing rows
in the database don't have that net
worth field yet so if we made it
required or we made it required without
some sort of default value it would mean
that all of our existing rows in the
database would be invalid and if we were
to ever read them from the database in
our code we could potentially break our
application and cause an error so by
making this thing optional or making it
nullable it means that our code is
actually going to be forwards compatible
which is great and by definition all of
this stuff is also backwards compatible
because say I have a piece of code that
reads from the database and you know it
doesn't expect the net worth field to be
there but there is a net worth field in
the data it will just ignore that field
and operate as per usual so again this
is really great but even still protocol
buffers and Thrift do have some
disadvantages
I keep mentioning that they basically
require a file on the part of the coder
to go ahead and write out the data
schema so what that means is that you as
the programmer has to know about the
schema of the data at compile time but
there are some points in life where this
isn't always possible imagine that you
have some sort of database and you've
got a server a and a server B and they
keep publishing rows to the database and
those just change over time they could
even be rows from like an external
company or someone else and you're
basically just ingesting them into your
data warehouse or data lake or whatever
it may be your Hadoop or anything like
that and you don't even know what the
format is going to be but you want to
make sure that once you do have all of
those rows of data that you are
compressing them as necessary so let's
imagine now again that server a is
publishing a thousand rows and server B
is publishing two thousand rows well we
actually just want to be able to create
data schemas for those on the Fly and
that is kind of what this framework
Apache Avro does so Avro is very similar
to Thrift and protocol buffers with the
exception that in instead of giving all
those fields unique tags or numbers what
it does is it basically just creates a
schema based off of the names of all the
columns and it does this in a way that
is very smart and we'll cover that in a
second so basically from server a we can
create an average schema called version
8.00 and then from server B we can do
the same thing with version B .00 which
is great
so let's go ahead and continue this
example because it's not so simple right
even if we give all of these a thousand
rows and extra fields that basically
says here's the Abra version right 8.00
and then we know how to read it in the
database there are often going to be
times where say I want to be able to
read the data on server B that I
published from server a and server B
doesn't actually have access to the
format of the data in advance so in this
case abro is actually able to perform
some cool things for us so let's imagine
we have some adverse schema database
right and we'll hold this on our
database it's useful for the database to
actually decode the data because we need
to be able to have all the schemas in
order to read the data and we've got our
8.00 and our B point zero zero formats
so you can see that the difference
between them is that they both have the
field name
but net worth is an A and net worth is
not in B sorry for my ridiculous check
mark there so what we can actually do is
we can call a basically the writer
schema and we can call B the reader
schema because we want to read data on
server B that was written from server a
we'll read from the database
so what can Avro actually do for us well
it'll do the following it'll basically
rectify the writer and the reader schema
in a smart way so it'll see that both of
these things have the field name and
it'll match those right so it'll
basically say okay I know that about
this field I'm going to go ahead and
read it it'll look at uh some field
called net worth and it'll say I've
never seen net worth before I'm just
going to ignore it well that's fair
enough because that's only in the writer
schema but not in the reader schema and
then finally we have this field
attractiveness so server B expects some
field attractiveness but it doesn't see
it in server a it's not present so we
have to do then is make sure to provide
all of these columns with a default
value in the case of attractiveness it's
an INT so I imagine it would be zero and
then basically server B would fill that
value 0 in for attractiveness when
reading all of these rows so that's how
Abra would go ahead and rectify kind of
the writer versus the reader schema if
the reader doesn't have access to the
writer schema often it should because
again there should be a centralized
repository of average schemas right if
we are all writing to Hadoop then Hadoop
should go ahead and store all of those
schemas in some separate database that
everyone else has access to them but
that's not necessarily always a
possibility so again Abra is a really
smart thing it's super useful when
you're doing a ton of data ingestion to
be able to kind of update your schema on
the fly if you don't know how things are
going to be in advance
all right guys well I hope this video
helped as per usual um I'll be back in
about a week and then hopefully once I'm
back to Chicago I can start uh actually
posting videos on a more consistent
basis so looking forward to it and I
will see you guys soon